and i'm always interested when those
strategies fail
that to me is when the real story
has a chance a deeper story has a chance
to be unearthed
why do we love other people's stories
that's a very interesting question
uh
i think we're drawn to other people's
stories because we get tired of our own
i think we're narrative beings and that
in so many ways we
who we take ourselves to be is really
who
we are cast in the story that we
fabricate that we created at a very
early age unconsciously you know perhaps
the family were born into and a whole
narrative gets created that gives us i
think the reassurance that we know who
we are
but unfortunately for most of us i think
the stories that we
inherit don't generally lead to
happiness
and i think that uh
the fascination we have in stories of
any kind is we'd like to see alternative
stories certainly alternative endings
generally and we'd like to be able to
reconsider the stories that we've told
about ourselves
do you think that's why some of us just
love the the dark cinema going into a
movie theater because we're almost able
to get out of our own
body it's like an outer body experience
because we're then going to live
life through someone else that's a
that's a very interesting comment yeah i
think there's something about the
darkness
which
in a funny way allows us not to be seen
so much of our lives we want to be seen
so much of our motivation is to be seen
as to felt is to feel that we've been
seen and yet we can we can be imprisoned
by uh often what we project others see
in us you know our darkest fears so i
think there's a great uh
liberating quality to going into a
darkened cinema where you're not going
to be seen
and you can perhaps then maybe feel
greater freedom to give vent to your
full
uh you know the full expression of your
feeling life
what makes you such a good storyteller
well thank you for saying that
i think i'm a good storyteller when i'm
invested in the story i'm telling
when i'm
truly curious about
finding a meaning within it or a thread
to follow
that i am truly
curious about and that and that permits
me
it makes me better able to make
discoveries within myself
i also find that uh as a storyteller
i have to stay
par
part of me is of course the one telling
the story but another part of me always
has to be the audience as well because i
have to i want to be experiencing the
story as i'm telling it
because that's the best barometer i have
to how it's going to be experienced by
the audience
uh
so i'm constantly assessing or i try to
what would make this interesting to me
and
you know i think the stories that i tell
it work are when i've succeeded at
finding those things
a little bit of a quote here
a story is more than simply what happens
it includes the meaning
of what happens yeah
i don't think it's acknowledged enough
how
much the director in any format feature
or series television even working on an
existing show
how much
responsibility really the director has
and power to define what the story is
because as you pointed out as i
mentioned in my book
a story is not simply what happens it's
the meaning of what happens it's it's
as the director you can
acquaint you can define what is at issue
you can
help generate the subjective states that
are required for moments in a story best
to land in an audience and
what a story is about
[Music]
really is determined by
so many other factors
in addition to what happens it's
it's the intentions of the characters
but who are performing the actions it's
it's uh
it's it's understanding what strategies
are being employed by the characters
and i'm always interested when those
strategies fail
that to me is when the real story
has a chance a deeper story has a chance
to be unearthed because that's when you
get an opportunity
to see how imagine anyway how real human
beings react
authentically that's something i'm
always
after authenticity the one thing that
that i
can't
tolerate is when i feel something is
fake or inauthentic
because that doesn't speak to us as it
doesn't it doesn't invite us to come
alive ourselves i often think of stories
as storytelling as
in film and television is making the
written word come alive and i think in
so many ways i notice within myself i
often you know feel i go through life in
many situations dulled and kind of
self-protective and presenting a persona
to the world and not really being fully
present
what i love about directing
is in many ways
it's a little funny to be saying this
but in many ways i feel most alive most
present
when i'm
telling a story and working with actors
and working with the cameraman or woman
to really uh
find the truth and the depth of the
story because i'm fully attuned i have
to be to what's happening within me am i
feeling stimulated am i feeling
intrigued am i feeling uninterested
which generally is when i realized more
digging is needed this is when i have to
go in and and help the actors find a
richer inner life or richer subtext or a
richer dynamic between the characters
well and that's a great point that you
made earlier about like inauthenticity
and we all wear masks you know and wear
them in different situations and
i think that's the beauty of cinema as
well is that we can kind of take off our
mask for a moment and watch whether it's
someone else's mask or a mask they're
trying to not wear whatever it is and
and and rest our own for a little yeah
you're reminding me of a story uh that i
recount in my book i have a a chapter on
this directing the show homeland oh
great and uh
while i directed many of
episodes of that series and some more
high profile than the one i wrote about
what really interested me in this
particular one is that it was uh it was
it was an episode that kind of departed
from the high stakes international drama
and focused on a custody trial for uh
carrie mathis and claire dane's
character uh battling with her sister
who
for for several seasons had kind of been
adversarial
uh with uh
carrie
over
how to parent carrie's child and so it
comes to a head in this trial and
in it uh
carrie arrives at the understanding that
she's going she voluntarily relinquishes
custody
to her sister
despite the fact that there's no one in
the world she loves more than this child
so that's a huge transition that she
would have to make and the writers uh
wrote it in a way that uh
gave me very little to work with because
because uh
it it they wanted carrie not to have any
cross-examination or call any witnesses
it was simply a litany of people coming
to the stand attacking her as a parent
and uh my job as the director was to
make this a compelling courtroom
sequence and
there needs drama there needs opposition
there needs not someone who's not just
folding her tent at the beginning of the
the sequence and then getting piled on
for the whole time so i had to kind of
figure out ways to
have care i knew what the ending had to
be kerry had to arrive at this
understanding
uh
but i had to figure out ways for the
audience to be cute that she was still
fighting for her for her custody of her
child but the key moment the writers had
had uh told me they thought was the
turning point for her was when her
sister calls her a hero
and
despite the fact that they'd been you
know fighting tooth and nail for several
seasons over the treatment of her
daughter and particularly in this
courtroom trial
there's something wrang inauthentic
about that i thought why would carrie
simply be by being called a hero by her
sister agree to turn over her child it
felt to me
that a more honest response from someone
in her position and again that goes to
consulting my own feelings why would i
make a momentous turn like that if if
someone who was about to take from me
the person i cared most for in the world
if they simply called me a hero
why wouldn't i just think that that as
simply a bone they were throwing to me
to assuage their own guilt for what they
were doing why would i give it
credibility so i was struggling with
this question of
how to make something feel credible
and what the writers had told me didn't
feel sufficient enough so i embarked on
a kind of
difficult exploration about
you know what could make this authentic
and i couldn't get a rewrite the rewrite
might have addressed it if i if i asked
for a different dynamic happening
but they were insistent no we don't want
this to uh we want it to be just just as
it is so it became my job
to make it feel
uh
feel authentic and you know there's a
quote i wish i could yeah oh please
we'll see your book yeah yeah i do i'm
going to get
like here's my book directing great
television
golden age so this issue of how to make
the uh
moment credible uh brought me to this
realization i wrote about in my book
in a story you can want specific things
to happen
you can say that they happen
and and you can do your best to justify
why they happen
but that's not the same as creating the
feeling that they credibly have happened
bad drama is filled with false moments
in which characters go through
transformations that have not been
earned with false insights and false
feelings ramrodding the story along
in some ways well i can go on but i mean
that's that's the the key point to me is
it's like yeah you can say well this hap
this is an example of the earlier
question you asked about you know what
is a story you can say story well the
story is this but if the audience isn't
taken with you if they don't have the
feeling that something has happened not
simply that you've told them that it's
happened or you see that it happens you
have to have the feeling that it's
justified that it's that's it's honoring
the truth of the story and that it's a
natural outgrowth and an interesting
development you know within the story
so uh what i realized let me see i think
there's some more oh yeah so so i was
struck with this difficulty of how to
justify
uh claire danes uh
playing carrie mathison her turn
and uh and i wrote this which i i think
is the passage i'm looking for
moments of reckoning that have moved me
either in life or in great storytelling
have taught me that transformation has a
chance to occur when people honestly
confront something about themselves that
they've been unaware of or strenuously
denying
when they give up their own failed
strategies or self-deceptions it can
feel like a death transformation starts
with being willing to admit to painful
truths which can break through our fixed
ideas about ourselves and our defenses
keeping them intact
the possibility for grace to appear
giving the possibility arises for grace
to appear giving us a fuller awareness
of and forgiveness for who we really are
dramatizing this to me is the height of
great storytelling and transformation is
probably the most personally meaningful
theme i am drawn to explore in any story
uh
well i can continue or i could just kind
of say that what what occurred to me um
i'll read it for this homeland episode
the writers demonstrated a similar
understanding in how they described
carrie's journey she finally sees how
unfit she's been as a parent and this
painful reckoning leads her to do the
right thing for her daughter but it was
not landing for me nor would it i
imagined for the audience
in thinking so i was then relay what i
continue to write about so i was so the
the
the centerpiece of the courtroom drama
was going to be the sister whose
character's name was maggie
when she gets up and gives her testimony
and this is what the writers have
thought okay she's going to call her a
hero and it's going to magically
change carrie's attitude towards her
sister
and uh and for the reasons i expressed
earlier i didn't think that would land
for the audience i thought carrie would
say yeah right you're piling on you're
taking from me the big the most
important person in my life and you're
telling me i'm a hero and i'm supposed
to fault i don't think so i'm not that
simple or as hamlet says said with the
flute player i said how do you think you
can play me as easily as you play that
flute
so i started to think what would move me
if i were in kerry's shoes and that's
really what i do as a director i have to
do i have to kind of put myself
in each of these characters positions so
that i can consult myself i have to be
my own barometer for what i think works
that's the only chance i have to
communicate
i have to assume that if it affects me
there's a chance it's going to affect
the audience
so uh
it struck me that i was thinking of the
story
incorrectly and this goes to the other
fascinating thing about storytelling is
defining the story
it's not simply it's not just a story
about uh
carrie giving up custody of her child
it's also could be defined as the story
of a rapproche mom between two sisters
a coming together of two sisters and how
would that be and that goes to the
point i tried to make when i was writing
about transformation how you have to
have a painful reckoning so i thought if
i were in claire danes carrie's position
in the court what would move me
would be if i saw
that
my sister testifying was going through
almost as difficult
a reckoning as i was being asked to go
through and giving up my daughter
and i started to realize maybe my focus
has been wrong maybe maybe the focus
should be on the sister's testimony and
i started to look at it and i realized
that there was an opportunity here to
give her an entirely new subtext that i
thought would bring about the desired
result
and in the testimony she gets up and she
continues to pile on you know she says
yes she did this terrible thing and she
did that terrible thing and then she
asked the judge may i just deliver a few
uh
remarks and the judge says yes and this
was all written not a word of the script
was changed
and she looks at what she'd written and
then she puts it down and she says may i
just speak to her directly and the judge
says okay
and she begins to recount their history
and she says you know when when i was
young and you you know you were you were
always you know you were the star of the
family you were very talented and i i
envied you frankly and you know i
admired you but i also
you know felt less than you uh and you
know you you're a hero you do many
things i could never do but you know
there are other things more there are
other things besides being a hero and
she goes on to you know and how i
understood that from the tone meeting
with the writers was well she's just
trying to de-escalate she's trying to
kind of you know say look this isn't
personal you know we were sisters and we
had a life and i don't hate you in fact
i think you're pretty great in many ways
but you're not a great parent
and i thought that that was what was not
working coming in with that intention
with that subtext so i started to think
well
what if
maggie has to go through as painful an
inner reckoning as we're asking carrie
to do what if and this is what occurred
to me what if she's never before
admitted what if this wound she
describes is current
what if she still feels inferior to her
sister what if it's the most painful
thing in her life to acknowledge that
she's always felt
inferior that she wasn't loved as much
as carrie and that she's never before
admitted it for fear of really coming to
touch that deficiency
and what i thought was wonderful about
that was
it also kind of accounted for previous
season's behavior because she was always
i always felt in these scenes a little
sanctimonious with meg with kerry
carriers off doing these amazing things
you know preventing the next you know
world trade center event and she's being
but you weren't there for your daughter
you know and so it was a little there
was something a little off
and uh
and so i i then i went further thinking
well okay so why
why would she be motivated to say this
precisely now
why would she in this public setting and
that that's also what makes it more
poignant is in this public setting she
was admitting something she'd never
before admitted to anyone including her
husband including carrie
she and so if she gave it that subtext
it would if it was filled with that much
pain and angst and
sense of inner deficiency to say this is
who i am i feel
nothing around you
why would she do that then
and i and the answer again it's a series
of directing for me is so much a matter
of inquiry of asking questions and then
your inner resources can come and answer
and and what was coming to me was well
uh
she's doing this may be her last chance
to ever talk to her sister
she's taking away her daughter
this may be the only form her sister
will ever give to her
and if at some future time and she knows
she's doing it for good reasons because
this child is suffering
but if at some future time some imagined
future
it came out carrie learned that she her
sister really did harbor this resentment
and even hatred of her sister as a child
that was still carrying through it would
cast this proceeding in an abhorrent
light it would make it would give carrie
the opportunity of interpreting what
happened as a selfish act as someone who
was just trying to get back and that's
not why she was doing this she was doing
it
she was acting from her best self in
trying to save this child
and so she needs to come clean
she needs to take this public setting
to come clean this is who i am
i'm acknowledging it and i'm
acknowledging now so you understand
that's not why i'm doing this i'm
hurting myself in saying this
but i'm still
convinced that this child will suffer if
you don't give up custody to me
and uh that opened up the whole scene so
that i understood well carrie's
transformation
i can believe she the sister will win
credibility with carrie if carrie gets
to watch with us as the audience this
painful inner reckoning that maggie goes
through and then just to conclude this
so what was the moment of transformation
it it's not that she tell she tells
carrie she always thought she was a hero
it's the credibility that she wins in
making this personal confession
that opens carrie to hear the next thing
she says
which is to tell her
you are a hero you are motivated by you
know
the uh your destiny is to do what you do
so i know now you're saying you're going
to be a better parent i know now you're
saying you will not ever you know betray
you know your daughter in any way
but how can you know that isn't it more
true isn't it more true to say that the
next time a world crisis happens you
won't be able to resist
isn't it true that the record shows that
can't you acknowledge that that you're
going to wound her again just in the
same way you've heard all these
witnesses testify the many ways she has
been wounded even though your intentions
now are good
isn't it inevitable you will and because
carrie can now accept that as true as
coming from an authentic place it
permits her to open drop her own
defenses against her sister
and see the truth of it
and make the transformation